[音楽]
最も早いん
最も強かっ
最も美しく
すべてのことを犠牲にして
一つのことをつきっ
岩バー瞑想を作り上げる刀鍛冶のようなと
思います
それがアスリート
僕はそれが幻想だと思います
スポーツの言葉に
アスリートは突然スタート地点には現れ
ないという言葉があります
それは
華やかな舞台で雪だ的なパフォーマンスを
するだけでなく
その裏でそれ相応の
準備とコストがかかっているいわば教訓の
ようなものなんです
それを選手だけでなく観客が理解している
からこそ
ともに感動体験ができるのです
だからこそ
2020年の東京オリンピックの延期は
全てに大きな衝撃を与えました
オリンピックは僕たちにとって神様でした
小さい頃から当たり前のようにやってきて
英雄が生まれ
このドラマに人々は巻
そして涙するよ
1秒でもを超える言葉をなかった
オリンピックかー
1年間も駅されてしまう
アスリートたちはみな驚きそして落胆し
ましたん
もちろん僕もその一人です
オリンピックは延期され
次の試合がいつになるのかもわからず
その上練習場も閉鎖されてしまいました
アスリートの1使命である勝つことを
取り上げられた僕は
一体自分は何者なんだろう
そう考えずにはいられませんでした
そのような状況を受け
僕は今まで受けていたスポンサーとの契約
を全て保留にしました
そこには
次の試合がいつになるのか分からないので
目標が立てられない
練習場が閉鎖されてどのように強くなれば
いいのかわからない
こんなアスリートに援助をお願いします
なんて事が言えるとは思えなかったから
です
そしてえええんとも覚える自主隔離の中で
少しずつ自分の中のアスリートとしての
意識が薄れかけていくことに気づいたの
です
それはまるで自分の存在価値が剥がれ落ち
ていくかのような感覚でした
しかしそんな時にふと1冊の方が目に
留まりました
ドイツの社会学者マックスウェーバーに
よって表されたプロテスタンティズムの
倫理と資本主義の精神という本です通称ぷ
ろり
その中でウエバーは資本主義の礎を築いた
のは活発な消費や花柄よくではなくそれと
は真逆の
僕の精神であると論じたのです
大学時代先行していた哲学のレポートを
書くために
なんとなく回本多の隅しまっていたその本
こそが僕のメリット待った本です
この方が僕に大きな影響を与えたのです
少しだけ内容を紹介させてください
この本はなぜカトリックの影響を受けて
いる国よりもプロテスタントとりわけ
カルヴァン主義の影響を受けている国の方
が
経済の発達が早かったとかというものを
分析したものです
カトリックには寄付をすることによって
与えられる免罪符によって罪を軽減させ
られるシステムがあります
アルシュお金ですくいを変えるのです
しかしプロテスタントはそれを受け入れる
ことはありません
なぜなら人間の剤が髪に干渉すること自体
がおこがましいと考えられていたからです
プロテスタントはお金から救いを見いだす
ことはありません
ではどのようにして救いを見出しているの
でしょうか
カルヴァン主義の考えに予定説というもの
があります
それは人間は生まれながらに神によって
救われるか救われないかをあらかじめ決め
られているということです
つまりどんなに寄付をしてもどんなに教会
で祈っても救われない人は救われないの
です
この考え方は今までの文化や宗教家の中で
生きている我々には衝撃的です
ですがこの考え方が重要になってきます
当時の人々がこの考えをすんなり受け入れ
て神様がもう決めちゃっているんだから
もうどうでもいいやと思えていたとは考え
にくいですよね
もし僕たちがその場にいてその考え方を
信仰していた場合どのように考える
でしょうか
ふとした時にえっ結局使われるのをすくわ
れないの結局どっちとなるはずです
そうして疑問は晴れることなく次第に本当
に救われているのだろうかという不安に
襲われるのではないでしょうか
そこでプロテスタントの人々は信仰の身
だけでなく職業労働を通して救いの革新を
求めたのです
職業労働は当時
転職と呼ばれていました
彼らは神の意思実現のために自分たち人間
を生み出されていたと考えていたため
与えられた営めを全うすることが神の意志
を実現することに直結すると信じていたの
です
つまり働くことによって不確実性の中に
納得顔自力でもたらしたのです
だからこそ贅沢をせず怠けることもなく
禁欲的に働くことができたのです
そうなると一つの問題が生じてしまいます
お金が増えてしまうのです
彼らは禁欲的に生活し労働を行っている
ためお金が貯まってしまうのです
これは困りました
快道のないお金をどのように使うべきか
しかし彼らには唯一お金を使うことが許さ
れたものがありました
総労働に対してです
初めは手作業だった労働が機械化し効率が
上がりさらに収入が増え恒常化していった
のです
そうして資本主義そのものがプロて
スタート中に生じてしまったというのが
プロリンに書かれていることです
もちろんこれは一説に過ぎませんが
非常に面白い内容となっています
ぼくはこの本の内容に強烈な気しか覚え
ました
まさに今僕が直面している状況に近いの
です
オリンピックの開催はある種アスリートに
とっての救いの形です
なぜならオリンピックというのは
reit の人生において一つの集大成だ
からです
その集大成があるかないかによって目標と
希望を持って歩き出すことができるのか
暗闇の中前も後ろもわからず絶望のまま
動き続けなければならないのかが決まるの
です
開催されることを信じて前に進み続ける
言葉だけなら簡単ですが当方もない努力の
対象が消えてしまう恐怖は常にあります
だからこそ信じるに値するのか
当時は自分自身をみんなが見つめ直すしか
できませんでした
しかしそれだけでは何の解決にもなりませ
ん
僕はどんなことでもいいから何か自信を
持って前に進みたい
そう考えた時プロリンの予定説が頭を
よぎりました
開催されてもされなくてもオリンピックで
メダルを取る人はどう動くのだろう
まずはそう考えてみることにしました
現場で活動費をもらうことは難しいから
自力で調達しよう
そして体力もうとしてはならない
何か体力を通さずに資金調達できる方法は
ないか
そう思案することで僕はウーバー一の配達
になることを思いつきました
慣れない配達業ではありました当然今まで
のように大きな支援がないため少額の奉仕
を積み重ね行くことしかできませんでした
ブーバー is がアプリに加算されて
いく金額は一つの配送毎に500円程度の
ものでしたがそれが増えていくということ
は金閣以上の喜びがありました
目標とする人物像に少しでも近付けると
いう喜びでしたこうやって僕はこの子の中
にいったい自分自身が何者であるのかを
考えることにとらわれることなく
オリンピックに出場しメダルをとる人間の
行動思い浮かべることで自分もそのように
過ごしたのですそれによって予想だにし
ないことが起きました
世界中のメディアに注目されたのです
メダリストがムーバー is をやって
いる
初めは飛サンダー3とがいるぞ
というようなストーリーを作られていまし
たが
次第に世界のスポーツパン屋奪いずを
ドライバーまでもが応援のメッセージを
くれるようなと思う
この時
昨年のオリンピックを開催するという言葉
を信じきれない状況の中でも自分の
思い描いたオリンピックに出場する手術を
終えかけるだけで世界から oaして
もらえるという大きな自信を得ることが
できたのです
冒頭でアスリートのイメージは幻想である
と僕は言いました
実際僕もこのころ中を経験するまではその
幻想にとりつかれていました
reit の価値は勝負に勝つこと
それに対して企業がアスリートの勝利に
価値を見いだし投資という形で支援をする
それだけがスポーツの分かりやすい形だと
しかしこのような考え方だけではスポーツ
界に不測の事態が生じたとき
選手とスタッフの唯一の目標である勝利が
失われてしまうのです
これでは救われない形で終わってしまい
ます
アスリートみんなが抱く幻想やしがらみに
縛られてはならないのです
ですが今回残念ながら僕はオリンピックの
メンバーに選ばれませんでした
率直に言って悔しい気持ちでいっぱいです
オリンピックに出るために行動し続けた1
年ではありましたがそれが報われることは
ありませんでした
3とにとってオリンピックは一つの集大成
ではあります
ですが終わりではありません
オリンピックが終われば世界選手権や
ワールドカップ
そしてパリオリンピックと終わることなく
続いていくのです
次から次へと自分の救いを再設定されそれ
に向かい続けていくのです
でもそれって好きじゃなきゃできないこと
なんです
僕はプロリンを通して僕の行動やスポーツ
のあり方を語ってきましたが最後は理屈
じゃなくて心が決めることなんです
このだによって多くのアスリートがその
キャリアを終えました
しかしそれを勇気ある決断など僕は思い
ます
止めることも才能だからです
救われないことを嘆いていても暗闇にただ
飲み込まれてしまうだけです
だから新しい救いのルートを再設定する
ために必要な決断などです
でもアスリートがその競技を続けることを
選択するその根底には好きだからという
強烈な思いがあるのです
それは誰にも止めることはできません
またプロテスタントからしてみても
その仕事にそれだけの愛情を持てるという
ことはまさに天職なのです
だから人々を感動させめっ今日させること
ができるのではないでしょうか
その競技を最も愛し
続けるもの
それが僕脳もアスリート像です
皆さんには続けている仕事はありますか
僕はアスリートを続けます
だって好きですから